so today is that men's rights activist
versus feminist
[Music]
hello I would yes an intersectional
feminist I've already identified which
abroad I'm gonna hate the most
yeah the best kind back our disclaimer
for those who don't know an
intersectional feminist is a girl who's
a feminist but also acknowledges hey
black people exist
Marxism to me feminism is fairness I
think that it's unfortunately misguided
feminism is a flow of movements
aggression advocating for the human
rights of man as a class I start
laughing hi my name is Zack and I am 24
years old this is Chris I'm a PhD
student at the University of Southern
California and I'm also titled my
specialist who challenges discrimination
against men or college campuses I'm 30
years old hi I'm Derek I'm also go by
Brandi oh I'm youtuber and I also muscle
noticin in cell which is it
involuntarily celibate I don't know what
but I hate this kid already
different but equal
I know as a woman that I don't have the
same physical strengths men and women
are built differently I think whenever
things are built differently it's for a
reason yes this is also why we say males
should not compete against female sports
love to be like oh my god men are so
much stronger than us we were scared and
now same time they're like let the men
compete against the women I'm just like
what why did you use that voice I was
like make up your mind
pick one but at the same time the amount
of limits that have been put on women
historically like the fact that not too
long ago we were just allowed to like
start voting even today like the wage
gap just all types of stuff like like
just stop bringing up the wage gap it's
been debunked by almost all credible
economists stop women just don't have a
lot of rights that are just it should
have nothing to do with what gender we
are to be able to be paid equally or
just be treated with respect so yeah I
do believe that of course there are
biological differences between men and
women and of course there should also be
legal equality of course I disagree with
the idea that women face systemic
discrimination you just mentioned the
wage gap which has been debunked so many
times you're this guy you're crossed
whatever his name is curse at curse at
and curse at Big Ups to you brother I've
studied evolutionary biology quite a bit
and men and women are very different
from not just a physical you know the
bone structure the neurological
department as well as well as the
chemical balances and also I don't
believe that men and women are equal
under the law either they should be
rather children are not equal under the
law and it's not because we hate
children it's because we love them and
we want to protect them I want to know
that you brought up children being
unequal to adults I just hope you
weren't comparing women to children I
mean I
technically a comparison occasionally I
think he was planted on that team to
make them seem to say I don't need you
to protect me I just need you not to
harm me I can protect myself I'm very
capable of doing what I need to do okay
okay I think that toxic masculinity is
definitely a real thing
it's kind of just the idea of what
masculinity should be but it goes wrong
a lot of the times saying that violence
sex power being a controlling person
makes you a man I see it in very
unfortunate places like when the young
men were boys in my family even from
like toddler age are told you shouldn't
be crying boys don't cry and what that
turns into I see it when I'm in a
bookstore and a guy who tries to get my
number says why y'all always got to act
like that and he sincerely had this like
cracking voice like he was hurt but it
was an entitlement and that's toxic
masculinity oh wow okay oh you went from
kids being told not to cry to a god to a
guy asking you for your number and why
are you acting what is that what is what
or maybe she meant there was a comma
there that I missed if it's that I'm
sorry she said well I see it there and I
also see it there I think that you know
when you're showing your emotions
especially they're like you know random
people random women in some cases they
will view you as weak I was raised by a
single mother I loved her that's
sometimes seen our video that someone
seen our video
she's a few no she's my mom I love her
but I could have used being told to to
act like a man I think back there were
some cases where I was too emotional and
that negatively affected how I you know
what happened to me
I don't think showing emotions is a sign
of weakness I actually thinks it's a
sign of strength men do live shorter
lives and that's because of a repression
of emotions and it feels like you took
men suffering and men's issues you
reduced it to whatever can fits your
narrative yes and then you try to pass
yourself off as a hero men die for a
plethora of reasons before women do we
have more risky jobs men are far more
likely to be represented in the military
and the police force and almost all jobs
with high mortality rate men are far
more likely to be present so when you
say men are more likely to die because
they don't talk about their emotions you
are reducing the reality of what men
live suicide women are far more likely
to be depressed than men but men are
more likely to commit suicide and go
through with the process so yeah because
we believe in commitment I think that
men's rights activists are only men's
rights activists as a response to women
expressing that they want more equality
I don't think they focus on actual men's
rights issues and rather it's just an
attack on women in feminism the irony of
what she's saying is that exist is
exactly how people speak about feminists
you don't know because you haven't
researched it because if you had there
are plenty of actual men rights
activists who are working diligently to
help men with a lot of their issues
because up until recently there were no
shelters for men who have been abused
but guess who got that [ __ ] started
men's rights activists so when you can
think about a lot of the Proms that are
facing man it's not feminists who are
addressing these issues and I'm not even
mad at feminists for not addressing
these issues because I think any
movement has to have it set demographic
and it's set agenda and women can't be
fighting for men and women this is not
likely okay so the n-double a-c-p
doesn't fight for Asians okay every
group has its targeted demographic and
so if men want a group that advertises
for their problems which is the high
suicide rate the high depression rates
the high mortality rates and jobs if men
want a union that represents their
problems I don't see
anything wrong with it and when you
minimize it - oh it's just anti-women
what you are doing is you are minimizing
the real problems that men deal with
it's not just an example it's not
necessary all men I don't dislike men if
you have friends that are having locker
room talk as a man as an ally please say
something to your friends what do you
think about locker room talk I believe
that everybody has locker room talk they
just don't call it locker room talk
women have it feminists have it every
group have their own kind of locker room
talk basically people are saying stuff
behind closed doors that they know if
they said in public would be very
problem at any that's anybody that's why
we have the very wonderful phrase don't
say that than anybody everybody has said
anybody has that if you say no I don't
have that I don't do that yes yes you do
I've spoken to a lot of prominent
feminists who are on the news and who
are on all kinds of platforms and when
you speak to them off the air when you
speak to them in private they say some
really [ __ ] up if it's a healthy male
space jokes so he just got he was saying
his truth yeah like in a man and the
healthy men ever that's not healthy and
he's not able to do was born and he has
to shut up and it's funny that he's not
able to express himself yet you're
saying that people are dying men are
dying more because they can't express
himself and yet here he is trying to
express himself but can't finish because
you're their [ __ ] you guessed it you
write jokes that are harmful jokes are
not healthy because they just lead to
people normalizing things people always
say oh it's just a joke but when someone
else hears it they don't realize how
that resonates and again how that turns
into violence I always have to repeat
this feminists you guys can't cherry
pick when you guys like
science they don't if you believe in
science on climate change you have to
believe the conclusive science on this
one fact okay jokes do not lead to
violence the science is conclusive on
the fact that video games does not lead
to violence it does not lead to
normalization you guys have to stop
making this correlation because the
science is against you you can't say
science is right on one point and then
you dismiss the science on the point
that's convenient for you be consistent
they don't realize how that resonates
and again how that turns into violence
no I think healthy dialogue I don't
think men have to be toxic in order to
have a conversation I know plenty of men
that are able to have conversations
about healthy productive
what's toxic to you isn't toxic to me or
my group of friends who you are not some
kind of radioactive waste detector you
don't have the final say on what is
toxic what is not in hockey peanuts and
some people cannot eat peanuts is it the
peanuts that is bad or Yuda has a
reaction to peanuts so maybe you're
allergic to certain things which is fine
it's fine
is it not people with allergies god I
just keep going productive things just
like women aren't well it's not
obviously something that I have
personally experience with but only 1%
of all people on the d'être are women in
this country so I've been women and men
commit identical crimes women are much
more likely to for example escape the
death penalty and that's just plain
sex-based discrimination that's a fact
Yorker said is just coming in and
cutting this whole conversation up
sex-based discrimination look I'm
thinking about basic needs like around
the globe the women who don't even have
like proper like sanitary like products
guys like oh yeah there's judge
gender-based discrimination in the
judicial system I agree but I thought
people around the world can't get the
tampons
it's like where's the where's the
continuation of no correlation at all
man got it I don't know if it's the
editing or if it's just but it's very
low for that but if you want to argue
that women deserve free hygiene products
or the Taiji products shouldn't be taxed
I agree I agree
I would like to think that we could get
some common ground is when it comes to
the clear biases that are in the court
system especially in the marriage and
family court system right and and right
there is what I would advocate for when
it comes to men's rights I think a lot
of times when a movement is created the
other side thinks that they're being
attacked or think that it's some like
attempt at erasure that's not what
feminism is about at all what do you
need a whole men's rights activism
movement for I could I'm sincerely
confused who are you talking to were you
not just sitting there the whole time
when he was telling you about the
problems that men face do you do not
were you not listening we're good
even one of your own girls was like man
I have higher rates of suicide and
depression and then you sit there you
like what do you need a men's right
activist group from it the things that
stand Valli like that I'm hear from
y'all that are like violet to me come
from a place of like I am treated like
unfairly by the system versus a lot of
the things women are saying it's also
America in the system as well but a lot
of is like harm from men
how and where how and where what where's
this harm from men coming ok it started
when I was young I'm not going to talk
too long I was 16 got a bottle thrown at
me because I told her boy I know it
started when I was in a club a boy
touched me I said no he kept touching me
got to the point he got violent he gets
to the point that the only reason why a
man decided to stop touching me in the
bookstore I talked about earlier it's
because he realized my husband was not
too far away he said sorry bro never
said sorry to me that's why and that's
off the top of my head this is why I get
upset because I'm like I'm here to talk
about like how you feel but when you
just dismiss the fact that women
actually have experiences that's when it
seems like it's about more than your
rights it seems like it's about your ego
and that's where I get pissed off where
you tell another human being that their
experiences but they're telling you
right in front of your face is not valid
but he didn't dismiss you he just said
how and why do you feel you're
discriminated against but a lot of is
like harm from men how and where
where's this harm from men coming and
that's not a dismissal that's just him
wanting to know more it was just how she
took it to her he said okay how is talk
to me about experience and all the
feelings came over and I understanding
because what she's living is very
traumatic but in the day rage you can't
not ask you asking makes you a bigot and
makes you misogynistic no sometimes you
won't understand and that's why you ask
why then your rights
it seems like it's about your ego and
that's where I get pissed off where you
tell another human being that their
experiences but they're telling you
right in front of your face is not
valued I didn't say they were invalid I
said how and why I'm trying to
understand that's not a thing booboo the
man really just try to understand what
the hell going on okay I think some of
the things that you guys are touching on
such as the court system and gender
roles are a subject of patriarchy and
that's part of what women are trying to
dismantle is those traditional gender
are there is a feminist organizations
that have done anything for example to
challenge bias against men and fathers
in yeah can you please give me like a
list of feminist organizations that have
engaged in any meaningful advocacy they
are just those issues because they are
actually none okay I know that you came
with your little research or whatever I
think whatever I okay we're done
no we're done shut it down shut it down
shut it down the minute that yo and
listen Wow oh no no no give me the doll
no give me the daughter not hitting me
with that dog give me the dog no you hit
me - I'm not
No give me the dog no give me no about
giving your dog don't make me get it
because if I get it you're not gonna get
to hit me sir give me the dog we box at
each other give me the dog do you
realize that all this time you're
talking about
dismissal and now he's he's questioning
your Bing research and you're dismissing
him I think that has been significant
progress over the last decade or so
especially in the legal field but I
think there are still significant
disparities that need to be addressed
such as poor health conditions bias
against men in the criminal justice
system bias against men in family courts
and a bias against man in the
educational system especially in
colleges men unfortunately many of them
don't want to even have this open
dialogue that we're sharing right now
we need men to help be allies to help
speak to other men it strikes me like
the way you phrase this you almost want
men to say certain things that you want
them to say Oh grasses Margie it's curse
that you're my chief cursor I guess they
want to curse that you just kind of like
men being allies men talking each other
man etc I'm completely okay with that
but I'm not going to repeat like
feminists talking points to other men
you know what and that's interesting
thing it's like well you know feminists
always look talked about eyelashes it's
great being allied to us the problem
with that is that we're not equals I'm
an ally to you so long as I repeat
exactly what you say yeah that's not an
allied ship that's servitude yeah if I
cannot say a talking point that you
disagree with
then I am NOT on the same level of you
I'm below you and if you discard me the
moment I disagree with your views then
we aren't friends we aren't allies what
I am is your servant
[Music]
we all believe different things we may
be under the label of men's rights
activists but for example I'm probably
the most traditionalist person here I
think we should be allies but maybe us
being allies in a patriarchy wouldn't be
so bad guys a plant this guy that's
wrong you know what's going back to the
past wouldn't be so bad it would
probably be a lot happier if we were you
know getting married and staying married
and having kids and you know going to
church and all that
Lottie Dottie do all the work in order
to kind of make progress we need help
from people that will listen because
let's be real when we express our
concerns a lot of men refuse to listen
but they would be more likely to listen
to another man you out of our people you
are God
talking about when we express ourselves
they do not listen girls shame on you I
actively do this work I surround myself
with women saying I've been heard by a
man before I get that you have stories
but I mean that's actually my question I
haven't heard y'all stories like I've
set up here and said I have three on the
top of my head I have about 30 plus
properly and I haven't heard y'all say
this is what happened to me this is not
a competition
but who suffers the most but I mean as
also what that make you feel better if
they suffer equally as you are it also
doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
their stories are if I tell you that
women represent less than 1% of all
death row inmates that's a stat that's a
problem there may not be stories but
those are real problems if you come to a
discussion hoping to hear individual
stories of suffering as it as a means to
connect understand no no as it means to
understand a global problem then you are
wasting your time
we don't discover what our real problem
is by listening to a hundred anecdotes
we do it by gathering thousands and
thousands of data points and then
compiling it in order to understand what
the root problem is to summarize the
discussion you have one group who - one
guy really just focus on facts and
solution and another group who wasn't
interested in listening and went my
feelings I don't care about your stories
because your stories aren't an
indication of a larger systemic problems
creates bias right okay I feel empathy
for women being lost being this guy look
I feel empathy for your personal
experience but I cannot sympathize with
your ideological position because that
ideological position is built on a
fallacy and that phallus is actually
costing like very that's causing very
real consequences for men as a class in
this country so I understand that you
are here with us it's kind of the good
feminist so to speak that you feel
empathy for men and I believe you but I
do not believe your movement
I do not believe your ideology yeah
whose man is this though put it that's
the end of the video
ah well that was very painful to watch I
was I felt like who they picked wasn't
great for this I felt like they could
have gotten a male feminist on this they
could have gotten a female men's rights
activist on this they could have shown
different sides of the coin
you know the feminist role on an even
playing field except for the one on the
far left was a little nutty but even
Derek Derek was just he was trolling Oh
either plan he was taken away from the
conversation yet you know waste of time
it's like it's a ways of foot on down to
have people with extreme views they just
have to be coherent and makes sense and
if they don't then get someone who does
who shares those views because otherwise
it's a waste of time to have him just
roll in so yeah if you want to say oh I
believe we need a patriarchal society to
explain why and I would love to hear and
bring facts don't now he was just there
to pick people yeah he was just there to
piss people off to me he was just there
pretty much dismissed to MRA movement so
overall I thought the discussion was a
bit of a disappointment thankfully the
one saving grace was cursed that person
I thought was really great throughout
and then a couple other the Asian guy
and the black girl in the middle I
thought they were just kind of mad and
then the other three were just lost lost
children yes so that was my of the prop
lost some of the crop the fallen state
[Music]
you